The Joe Rogan Experience we have
epidemics in this country right now that
people aren't paying enough attention to
well the fentanyl epidemic that one
scares the [ __ ] out of me man that one
scares the [ __ ] out of me it really does
because people are accidentally dying of
overdoses it used to be if you died of
an overdose it's because you did A
Dangerous Drug you took a very risky
chance to do something that you probably
knew you shouldn't be doing whether it's
heroin or meth or something like that
but now people are doing things they
think are fairly innocuous
and it's laced with fentanyl and they're
dying well just across the border uh
just just South of San Diego in October
um of 21.
uh they busted
um
a drug lab
that was turning out 70 million
counterfeit pills a month
one lab
70 million counterfeit pills a month now
we don't know that they were all going
to come to America
but we know a shitload of them were
going to come to America
and the dea's estimate is that 40
percent of them
are laced with lethal
levels of fentanyl forty percent forty
percent
are least are are laced with lethal
doses of fentanyl
and poisoning fentanyl poisoning is the
number one cause of death for people 18
to 49 in this country yeah
and and think about that if and and what
what these kids need to understand and I
want
people to understand this and and I
don't care if you stop listening to Joe
and I talk right now and go call your
kid or go call your grandkids or your
friend's kids
the chance of them first off all these
pills you're buying on Snapchat
a hundred percent of them are
counterfeit they're buying pills on
Snapchat they're oh
they're buying
how does that work
you can buy a pill on Snapchat
and I'll I'll show you here let me pull
this up I know Jamie can't beat me to
this
if you do I
I'm gonna
really be impressed he's got it no he
doesn't either [ __ ] I'm gonna
Snapchat drug dealers how illegal drugs
are being dangled to kids on Snapchat
Instagram and other platforms
scroll down I'll see him if he was going
to react no I'm not reacting I'm not
reacting I'm looking and I because I've
got something
okay here we go
um like see these Xanax bars here
yeah
and uh maybe I can send this to Jamie
okay then here are the emojis that they
use to advertise it with
and then here is
the menu
so who is this cartels that are putting
these things up on Snapchat and okay you
order them on the Internet yeah here's
the deal
fentanyl is synthetic
and
it's all being
generated in China
so if you want to be a conspiracy
theorist this will get your conspiracy
juices
uh flowing are you airdrop open over
there yeah Jamie's Air Book Pro yes
okay
I just sent you four pictures and
they're gone so now you have them
okay it's all being generated or
synthesized in China
and then China is sending it to the
Sinaloa cartel
and the cartel is then turning it in to
these pills
and then these pills are coming into
America
and the DEA
estimates that they are intercepting
about 10 percent
and what they are intercepting
is enough
to kill every American
Jesus Christ the fentanyl is enough to
kill so here's the menu every American
L.A County delivery
it's like make it to that little there
he goes
so LA County delivery Nationwide
shipping low cost low stress highest
highs Dr Don guarantee
Mr Don 248
so look at all the stuff that they have
here perks
GMO OG gas and Edibles what does that
mean uh that's probably weed
gas really yeah THC crumble snow
Adderall 20 milligram scripts 2.5
milligram hulks what are those
what's a Hulk that's a type of pill off
the top of my head I wouldn't know but
I'm not it's a pharmapram bottles Ambien
10 milligram scripts hydros 10 mil what
is a hydro uh like a hydrocodone and
maybe I don't know I think
Jesus Christ
yeah now go to the um
go to the Emojis
that I sent you
it's one of the images I sent
and this is how they communicate
percocet oxycodone
so there's they have these different
emojis yeah there's that combination
yeah I mean different things what is
that little Emoji next to those two
pills that means Xanax it looks like a
truck
what does that mean delivery yeah
I think that means they'll deliver that
to your house this is like Postmates wow
you call you order this and they'll
deliver this to your house
in less than an hour and I've had
different sets of parents on who's these
are kids that and we do pretty good
background checks on these I'm talking
about and the title of the show we did
was one pill kills
because these were not kids that were
drug addicts they weren't doing heroin
and that sort of thing and we checked
because
like one of the girls we got her credit
card information we saw she ordered one
pill we went back like much ordered one
pill
and she wanted to get some sleep before
finals and
we found three quarters of the pill in
her top dresser drawer her parents found
it and the police came
because she broke it in half and then
broke it in half again so she took a
quarter of one pill
and they found her dead in the morning
because it had so much fentanyl in it
that it just killed her
and this isn't an overdose this is
poisoning
you think this is purposeful well
the reason they put it in there and
put this one up and the reason they put
it in there is because it's so highly
addictive
but they're not smart
or they don't care if they're killing a
certain percentage of their customers
but
here's the deal fentanyl is a synthetic
opioid that is up to 50 times stronger
than heroin a hundred times stronger
than morphine
so if you bite into this
you're dead when you hit the ground
and so she took a quarter of it
boom
gone
and
um
their estimate is that 40 percent
of these pills that they're getting have
lethal doses of Fentanyl and the ones
that don't
have enough in it that you are addicted
like that
so they come back for more and more and
more and more
um and now there are conspiracy
theorists including a former DEA guy
that believes that China
is manufacturing this stuff synthesizing
this stuff sitting to the Sinaloa cartel
who's flooding it into America
and they're just trying to poison or
drug Americans
um it's just another attack he believes
it's a terrorist attack
and it's interesting he has a demo
that he does he just takes a
a little packet of sweetener
and dumps it in his hand
and he says that enough that much
fentanyl's enough to kill 500 people
it's just
it's it's it's staggering
and we've got to get this message out to
the kids
don't do it it
those pills look exactly like the pills
that you get at the pharmacy and what
they're doing now Joe is they're putting
them in these pastel colors uh and I
think I sent you some of those Jamie uh
in the pastel colors they're making them
look like these candies that the kids
get
and kids are going to see these things
around and pick them up and think
they're like
Sweet Tarts or or whatever and bite into
them
um
if if I was a parent
I would go to the store and buy every
kind of candy I could find and as soon
as my kids came home from
trick-or-treating I would take their
pumpkin and dump it into the trash and
then fill it back up with candy I knew
was good and hand it back to them I
wouldn't let them take a single piece of
candy from trick-or-treating because you
don't know what's in there
that was always the fear right when we
were kids that someone was going to
sneak in we thought it would be a razor
blade in an apple or something yeah I
saw this going around but I heard a lot
of people pushing back a couple days
after this was made major headlines
because they were showing them say no
who's the expert I don't I'm just it
there was a lot of uh hubbub about this
viral picture because this went out the
D.A was talking about it but then I read
there was like no evidence that this was
real what was that that's what I read
well let's scroll down and see what they
say in terms of looks like candy DEA
administrator Alan or Ann uh Milgram
told CBS News in fact some of the drug
traffickers have nicknamed It Sweet
Tarts Skittles the DEA alert didn't
mention Halloween but fear is about
rainbow Fentanyl and the holiday went
viral
D.A warning meets skepticism from drug
experts drug policy experts contacted by
NPR agree there's no new fentanyl threat
this Halloween many are also skeptical
of the dea's original warning they don't
believe that Mexican drug cartels and
Street dealers have launched any new
campaign targeting children I don't see
any evidence that the DEA has produced
that supports that conjecture
I don't think they're targeting children
I think the fact that they are making
these things in pastel colors make
children vulnerable to picking these
things up yeah you you want to argue
over the the word targeting
if a child picks up something that
look you know I I said that young girl
that I was talking about took three
quarters of a pill or one quarter of a
pill
and three quarters of it was left in her
drawer yeah if she has a a younger
sister
or something that sees that picks it up
and it looks like candy and eats it
she's gone right yeah it's I'm not
saying we're targeting not saying he's
targeting yeah I don't care if you use
the word targeting or not
it's it's it's dangerous and I'm just
saying I'm uh
you know my grandkids they won't be
getting any candy out of that
and it's not that anywhere they're going
is going to be giving out front and all
the kids it's just they don't know where
they're right where it's coming from
yeah you don't you're not getting it
from a store
and that makes it dangerous and I
my point is
if you're in school and you're studying
for finals and you're not a drug addict
and you think well one pill is not going
to hurt
that's no longer true
you may be thinking I'll get some
Adderall
get me through my finals
that could be a fatal decision
it won't be an overdose it'll be a
poisoning
it's very dangerous
and if you're getting it from someone
other than a pharmacy
there's a high possibility
well
the dea's belief is that all of the
pills that you're getting on social
media are counterfeit
and that as much as 40 of them have
fatal doses of fentanyl lethal dose is
fentanyl because they're so
unsophisticated in their mix so it's not
a matter of poisoning as much as it's a
matter of they don't give a [ __ ] and
they're just I mean they're not like
accredited Labs these people are just
mixing [ __ ] up and they're making this
stuff up in a bathtub they're making it
up in a in a yeah you're mixing it up
and then they're putting it in a pill
press and letting it dry and shipping it
over here they
um
today on CNN they said they
arrested some uh it was either CNN or
Fox one of the two they arrested some 14
year olds coming across the border and
they had a couple of thousand pills on
them
um
and
uh who knows where it came from who
knows what else is in it right